[Música]
eu queria começar com o falando sobre o
que aconteceu quando o receptivo está
falando ah eu fiquei extremamente
assustado
eu falei gente o que será que eu tenho
pra pra contribuir pra poder falar com
as pessoas
a isso na verdade é um sistema que se
desenvolveu em de auto-sabotagem e ele
acontece o tempo todo o caminho com ele
na minha vida e brigo com ele o tempo
inteiro mas mais uma vez a
eu acho que eu consegui transformar esse
primeiro impacto que eu tive de ficar
nervoso e não tenho que falar numa no
momento de análise da minha vida do que
tinha acontecido quando eu lhe então que
o tema seria poder da realização foi um
momento que eu paralisei eu não não eu
penso em realiza em realização no
sentido de estar realizado e eu acho que
eu sou uma pessoa que sempre tem alguma
coisa que está buscando buscando a mais
e talvez por isso que eu tenha é o agora
colocando em perspectiva eu tenha
realizado tanta coisa
ela falou eu é o primeiro trabalhei com
a administração de de empresas
trabalhava numa empresa familiar com 27
anos eu já dirigi uma empresa com 100
funcionários trabalhando em três turnos
e fazia aqui ou até de bem feito
fazer de uma forma bem feito era recém
casado e m traz aquilo me trazia uma
certa segurança financeira mas não era
exatamente aquilo que eu procurava e
isso começou a acaba de ganhar um peso
maior peso maior até o momento de ficar
insuportável então imagina que todo o
resto estava todo o resto o casamento
estava indo bem o lado financeiro também
do bem
mas a infelicidade é monstruosa até a
ponto de chegar no primeiro período é
realmente de muita tristeza depressão
enfim é eo que sempre me tirava desses
momentos de de muita tristeza era quando
tinha um contato maior com o meio meio
artístico
mesmo na adolescência eu comecei a
tocando em bandas eu tocava piano então
que em algumas bandas a apresentação do
festival esse tipo de coisa
aí depois tive um contato com a
fotografia também e mas nessa hora a a
família requisitou então a presença para
trabalhar trabalhar com eles e eu acho
que foi uma das primeiras tomadas de
decisão errada da minha vida no sentido
de agradar somente ao outro e eu fazia
tudo bem feito família a família queria
só que o que eu acabei de inventar uma
super feliz com isso
enfim acabei acabei conseguindo sair da
empresa até por motivos de saúde porque
realmente não não tinha condição de
continuar naquele trabalho e comecei a
procurar várias coisas pra pra poder
fazer cursos no sebrae esse tipo de
coisa e comecei como terapia a usar de
novo a fotografia aquilo que me deixava
mais tranqüilo me deixava mais calmo e
rapidamente as coisas começaram a
acontecer inclusive numa velocidade
superior ao que eu estava querendo
porque o que me interessava muito na
fotografia a foto que eu vi em museu em
galeria
sempre quando viajei um rato de de museu
é gasta boa parte do meu tempo dentro de
um lugar em vez de tartá curtindo que as
outras pessoas curtem a me interessava a
fotografia dentro do universo do da das
artes visuais
porém mais uma vez por demanda externa
por pessoas me elogiando pelo que eu
estava fazendo eu me deixei entrar
há em alguns universos como publicidade
eu nunca tinha imaginado trabalhar com
publicidade na na minha vida
a moda há também não tinha essa é a
vontade é acabou que eu acabei fazendo
campanhas nacionais e internacionais
sempre cotado como um fotógrafo própria
chamada pra conversas e pra falar e eu
ainda estava infeliz e eu ainda estava
muito infeliz eu tinha de novo alcançado
um lugar eu tinha tinha é tinha
conseguido o reconhecimento e mesmo
assim não era isso e então eu fui atrás
foi atrás de terapia foi atrás de ajuda
para poder entender é o que é porque
isso me atacava eu comecei eu comecei a
ver que é a eu ainda não estava fazendo
o que eu estava querendo por mais que
esses sucessos apareceram por mais que
essas realizações aconteceram aquilo
ainda aquilo ainda me incomodava eu não
eu não dormi tranqüilo e no momento em
que nasceu meu filho estava com 37 anos
hoje ele está com oito anos de idade vai
fazer oito anos nesse momento eu lembro
que eu olhava ele à noite no berço
dormindo e eu falava nossa eu não posso
criar o menino se um pai frustrado e
isso é a coisa que mais me pegou
eu não imaginava que vai ser vai vai
crescer com um pai ranzinza chato que é
nada presta e nesse momento eu me sentia
muito dessa dessa forma a alegria de ter
o filho naquele primeiro impacto e logo
depois mas eu vou criar essa pessoa
dessa forma
resultado um segundo período depressivo
na minha vida
aonde aos poucos eu comecei a ver que e
como se perder clientes com isso dentro
da fotografia e comecei a ver que eu
realmente precisava achar o que estava
por baixo da da casa
o cara é o quê que o que me movia é
porque que eu sempre senti a falta de
estar no meio de arte e comecei com
pequenos passos a me aproximar mais
dessas pessoas aproximar mais do núcleo
de arte em curitiba em conversar com as
pessoas em expor meu trabalho eu sou uma
pessoa que por muito tempo foi campeã em
guardar trabalho excepcional
eu deixava tudo guardado e achava que
algum dia alguém me descobrir eu achava
que alguém entrar na porta do estúdio
falar olha hoje você tem uma exposição
no tate se acabou de ganhar no tempo
moda vai começar no mês que vem e e
então você só consegue ver onde está seu
trabalho mostrando só consegue ver onde
está o trabalho mostrando é é colocando
para discussão participando de grupos de
discussões e foi isso que eu fiz eu
comecei a freqüentar comecei a fazer é
aí preciso lugares mas eu ainda tinha
uma vontade que isso se tornasse avô eu
quero ser só artista mas dentro do do
mercado de arte mesmo de curitiba ou do
brasil isso é uma coisa super complicada
ou você está dando aula ontem que está
fazendo outra coisa e eu comecei a ser
chamado de volta para os trabalhos de
publicidade trata aí colocar um pouco da
minha visão artística sobre os trabalhos
então os trabalhos que começaram a
aparecer pra mim foi um trabalho muito
mais a é que me agradavam em que eu
poderia mesmo estar contribuindo e eu
comecei uma pessoa mais leve
nesses nesses momentos de de estar com o
cliente e eu já não queria fazer a foto
mais maluca do mundo que o cara não ia
adiantar nada porque ele ia conseguir
atingiu o target dele com aquela foto
mas antes eu ficava bravo porque achava
que ele teria que fazer algo
completamente inusitado e então essas
relações começaram a melhorar
é eu sei a ser chamado para vários
eventos relacionados à arte
já participei de um festival
internacional como artista convidado do
brasil e
em israel a fiz um projeto no canadá
agora num é no mês de abril
a voz por lá no mês de setembro a este
ano depois de 15 anos com uma produção
que artística que eu considero mesmo os
pequenos momentos que eu fazia isso no
começo da fotografia conseguiu a
primeira individual é em um museu e me
sinto uma uma pessoa que hoje eu agradar
a mim
hoje eu faço o trabalho que hoje eu eu
tento fazer é não é mais pra ganhar lá e
que não é mais ganhar nem não foi
conhecido era nem a questão do iraque
mas eu vejo que hoje muita gente ainda
fica em cima desse lugar de deter uma
aprovação através de lai kin ou e aí a
mesma aprovação que buscava na época eu
queria que o pessoal face nossa incrível
e eu consegui isso mas não era isso
então eu acredito que quando você tira
essa casca que você tira um tempo que
você vai ver realmente quem você é é um
momento em que se o trabalho que você
faz começa realmente a a a tocar o outro
a gerar algum tipo de questionamento ou
gerar algum tipo de de uma observação
por um tempo maior e não somente aquela
observação automática o trabalho é seu
há uma passagem que eu acho que eu
gostaria de de utilizar agora pra
encerrar além da aula é de tem muitos
esforços em tudo que vocês precisam
fazer vamos atrás eu fiz isso na minha
vida inteira eu entrei em muitos
trabalhos entre muitos projetos sem nem
saber como executar mas era a vontade de
entrar a tão grande depois que entrava e
tudo bem não dormia direito e atrás mas
conseguia a ter resultado na quilo e tem
uma passagem que a aconteceu com meu
filho alguns anos atrás do colégio e na
época eu lembro que pra mim isso foi um
pouco o susto já que vivendo há no
universo da arte ele a gente foi chamado
pra eles contarem sobre
a avaliação que o filho tinha teve
naquele mestre e tinham vários que era
só por uns quadradinhos com cor e tinha
um quadradinho estava em vermelho foi o
único que me chamou a atenção e eu fui
ver então o que era esse quadradinho
vermelho e lá estava escrito que o meu
filho não conseguia pintar as cores
dentro dos contornos e aquilo pra mim eu
precisei eu precisei pegar o menino eu
eu mostrar pra ele é diversos artistas e
lembra que ele achava que os olhos dele
nunca ficavam legais eu fui mostrar
picasso que uma mulher aqui outra aqui
pra ele se abre um mundo completamente
novo
eu falei se você quiser pintar fora do
contorno vai pintar fora do contorno e
acho que o que eu posso deixar hoje pra
pra vocês aqui é isso quem tem fora do
contorno
ok obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]